hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay we're going
to make we've already killed a couple of
these ladies
and we found some gizzards not enough to
cut the rope with I could use another
part I could cut a rope with one half of
scissors I mean come on
was it that wimp we got here anymore
lady damn it oh come on no I said back
off [ __ ] that's right okay oh then
they they're coming at me strong anymore
in here huh who's in here ah the Oh miss
me
yo yo ah gotta wind up my stick before I
whack them that's uh do I need one of
those I need I need everything I have so
I can and if I did need it I just use it
and drop pick what I dropped back up huh
anymore huh okay oh yeah
walk out walk all right all right you
wanna straight up
yeah man lot of sticks can I do a wield
sticks that would be awesome
so hardcore hey where's in [ __ ] any
scissors why can't I pick up their
knives that would be enough to cut it oh
here we go what do you mean inventories
full drop it then combine them into
scissors
there we go okay now hey there we go
okay now I'm good I'm good now let's go
cut that rope and be on our merry way
paratis oh I want to get out of these
woods okay come on come on use aah
[ __ ] again is that physics in in a
half-life game that's really impressive
the code managed decoded code in physics
into this game
here's that of the more likely option is
that they had to hand to animate the
debris but it was well done ah save yeah
watch out for the trees oh come on now
the trees are gonna get me good man that
made my hair stand on end
yeah the way trees I do all trees do
that oh okay you're in my way oh you're
not so scary okay okay
I go around you look up your skirt okay
that's obviously obvious wasn't right
okay okay okay
don't like don't like don't like you're
not like oh what's this
Oh way out ah huh what what was that huh
huh chainsaw man coming back please
don't buy those jeans I mean okay this
looks safe ow
I got a dick oh that's me oh boy
okay okay okay okay okay okay
look at me bro don't bro Oh
parkour up it what the hell okay I just
got
come on okay let me just look at it more
make sure
oh man
you probably guessed I can't even hear
me I'm in
come on
everybody forever
dammit oh come on that's a man fair
do you have instant kills well I don't
have a save point
aah huh is there a quick save please if
you guys know what quick save please
tell me because I hate going back far
when I die I know it's so cheap
how could how could I even get through
that last one I'll shut up
no all what that scary not huh
boy oh yeah number Braille all right
Oh Parker up would ya oh so Lee epic
skills oh okay here we go
gonna make it look there we go
come on Ariel
what the hell is that
I'll see how that can insta kill me as
you seems pathetic to die from that
Pappy in the face and then you'd be have
a broken nose maybe not blow you to
pieces
Oh
yes that is call I call that the
[ __ ] monkey style of fighting then
on his hand what a ridiculous monster I
wasn't even that scary I was just stupid
[Music]
okay
oh boy oh alright okay okay okay save
point save point
no no save point whoa hello Oh am I
finally out of the forest
please tell me yes my frame rates not so
good here probably because of the rain
half-life 1 engine um and not made to
handle rain like this
all right also for this game a man
mentioned it before but I have to drop
to one graphics card I have crossfire 58
50s but for this game I have to disable
crossfire because it doesn't make it
doesn't work with the game duck dog Oh
ma'am go to get you coming after you get
some hey car what's over here
anything what is that I thought I saw
something anything
no not gonna work okay whatever alright
doc here are chrome all right where ya
buddy
Oh finally a building probably not gonna
be any better than the woods
oh boy this seems pretty bad I can do
with the save point thank you very much
this save point there we go hello
finally and it is loud in here I hope
you guys can hear me ok but all the
ambient sounds going on is made it a bit
loud
ha this is out there hmm
no one creepy graffiti her I call it art
a lot of big city mayors wouldn't call
that alright but I'd do all right what
we got here
nothing nothing looking for a needle or
a bag hopefully somehow I lost my bag I
can't hold on to anything
what was that say reckoning for abit you
didn't fool Dibley looting elevator
doesn't work
open the gate blocking the staircase
what
these electricity question mark my
unsure of myself there come on ah shut
up
I'm not scared
ah shut up oh there's nothing in here
I've been to like every room now the
crazy monkey fighter is gonna come after
me off so scary oh here we go
I thought it said something about the
staircase lock being locked or something
I don't know
hello oh that's the gate okay uh-huh
I got here huh
someone wants some quiet almost too
quiet oh here we go
Oh a puzzle puzzle whack it with a stick
stick whacking whack stickin Oh a
flashlight
hey that's much better
oh yeah let's see Shane your battery
powered flashlight I'll drop the I'll
drop the lantern for that and plus
there's extra lanterns everywhere so
hang on
cool oh oh you can get some now walk
wait did I get everything I need it down
there was I supposed to fix something
let me go back just double-check real
quick it doesn't cast much ambient light
which kind of sucks but it's got a more
focus beam and I can actually see that
Holly's okay here we go aha that was it
really okay I'm so smart I saw a pulse
now he's realizing it huh oh my god duck
ah nope nope
you can't suicidally influence me now
Kenya Oh who you so scary I don't have a
gun
how about I do have a oh that's a baby
you are all talking about alright I
gotta go back up to the save point
because I have run out of time for this
episode so what where am I okay oh let's
get that knife your baby will do better
Oh Oh nope oh so pro okay that's all the
time I got for now thank you guys so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next part
bye bye